ونعمل على الحفاظ على سيادة مصر
من الهيمنة العالمية. بوتين يهدد
الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي.
جمهورية ايران الاسلامية لا تسعى
حماس وصمة عار في جبين السلطات
الفلسطينية. رغم اشتداد التوترات
عقيدتنا. بوتين علاقات الصداقة
مع مصر تسمح بتطوير الشراكة معها
الى عن اسلحة نووية او حيازتها.
ولا مكان لهذه الاسلحة في
الاحداث والتطورات. ترامب يسخر
من بايدن مجددا بسبب جلوسه في
ودعا لدعم دولي لهذا المشروع.
ليتهم بعدها اليونان بتحويل بحر
من هذا النزاع حفيد ارطغرل تمكن
من الحفاظ على علاقته رغم الحرب.
يقول والدكم عن اسرائيل? امام
الجمعية العامة للامم المتحدة.
استعداده للقاء بالزعيم الكوري
الشمالي فما سر هذه الدعوة?
احتفاء اسرائيلي بتصريحات وزير
الخارجية الاماراتي بافتتاح بيت
ليعلن بوتين ربيعه المنتظر.
السيادة الصينية في خطر.
احدهم يراهن على صموده بينما
الاخر ينتظر نصرا يطبخ على نار
التهديدات الامريكية تجاه اصحاب
العيون الضيقة لا تنتهي بعد
موسكو. اردوغان يكشف عن توصل
روسيا واوكرانيا الى تفاهم
هيجنز والفرقاطة الكندية فانكوفر
ابحرتا عبر مضيق تايوان. واضاف
بوتين بان غزوه يفشل. الخارجية
الصينية ندعوا لايجاد حل في اسرع
وتعويض الخسائر. روسيا واوكرانيا
تراهنان على معركة شتاء اوروبا.
يغرد في تويتر حان الوقت لتتعرف
على قادة العالم الثالث. هذا ما
يعتبر جريمة ضد الانسانية على حد
وصفه. يا لطيبة قلبك يا عثمان.
نعلق هنا. سنترك التعليق لكم.
ومن التطبيع الى التلميع
وواشنطن تندد. والصين تتعرض
لاختراقات بحرية من اطراف جديدة.
الدول الاوروبية والامم المتحدة
الى التحرك ضد هذا الظلم الذي
تعبئة القوات من اجل الحرب في
اوكرانيا يعد اعترافا من رئيسها
وستتصدى بحزم لما اسموها
التهديدات والاستفزازات والهدف
بين البلدين. رئيس الوزراء
الياباني فوميوكيشيدا ابدى
ايجا الى مقبرة للاجئين عبر
ابعادهم بشكل غير مشروع. داعيا
الانساني. قال اردوغان ان بلاده
بدأت في الاستعداد لانشاء مائتي
الاخطر. اجهزة الامن الفلسطيني
تعتقل مصعب اشتي القائد في كتائب
ليشهد هنا الخط الحدودي الفاصل
بين الصين وتايوان حالة من
سريعا من الصين. حيث قال الجيش
الصيني ان المدمرة الامريكية
لاول مرة منذ عقدين من الزمن.
هنا اردوجان يلتقي رئيس الوزراء
عواقب وخيمة لحد المواجهة
العسكرية اذا ضمت اجزاء من
الصين ترتكب خطأ فادحا اذا غزت
تايوان كما ستتسبب بعواقب وخيمة
شاملة مع الغرب. وزير الدفاع
البريطاني بن والاس اعلان روسيا
فاعلية اكبر. رد الفعل الاسرع
جاء من واشنطن لتحذر روسيا من
الاسرائيلي في نيويورك ليبحث معه
تطوير العلاقات الثنائية نحن لن
الف منزل في سوريا لضمان نحو
مليون لاجئ سوري الى بلادهم.
اردوغان يطفئ نار الحرب. مع
احتدام المعارك العسكرية وتصعيد
تعترف بهزيمتها الكبرى والانسحاب
من اوكرانيا. اتسمعون ما هنا
حتى لا يكون هناك اضطرار
لاستخدام الاسلحة النووية بل
اكد على ان الجزء النووي لالية
موجود ولكن الهدف هو منع اي نزاع
نووية هي تصريحات خطيرة ومتهورة.
مضيفا ومن الافضل لروسيا ان
النفاذ. لذا يرجى منكم سرعة
اعادة تعبئة الحساب.
ذلك بيان رسمي للجيش الصيني بان
قوات الشرقية في حالة تأهب قصوى
انه اصدر اوامر لقواته البحرية
والجوية لمتابعة الوضع. ليعقب
اعلان بايدن الدفاع عن تايوان
عسكريا اصدر وزير القوات الجوية
كان ذلك حقا مزاحا ليدخل هنا
حليف الابيض على الخط. نعم هي
الجديدة جاهزة وهي على الطاولة.
وستبدو الاجراءات السابقة
جمعه من الساحة السياسي حول ردة
فعل الغرب تجاه ما فعله بوتين.
الامريكية تحذيرا شديد اللهجة
لبكين. وقال الوزير الامريكي ان
تلوج اوروبا وشتاؤها القارص. وسط
محاولات لتحقيق مكاسب عسكرية
هادئة. برأيكم هل ستصمد اوروبا
ليكسب ام سينتصر شتاء اوروبا
العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي صرح انه
تم رفع درجة التأهب مع بدء الحرب
من جانبه الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان
قديروف **** قائلا خطة الانتقام
الوزراء الهولندي مارك روتين
الامر الذي اصدره بوتين ما هو
وقت يراعي المخاوف الامنية
والمشروعة لكل طرف. هذا ما تم
الا علامة على الذعر ويجب الا
نظهره على انه تهديد مباشر بحرب
الالماني. الاستفتاءات المرتقبة
شرقي اوكرانيا ومخالفة دوليا.
ردة فعل. وليس درس فيزياء بل هي
دراسة روسية بشأن ردة فعل
الطاولة الغربية ازاء اعلان
بوتين لتبدأ من المستشار
وعشرين مليون شخص يا لهذه
الارقام المرعبة ويا لسعير حربها
وستين جريحا. بينما خسائر روسيا
خمسة الاف وتسعمائة وتسعة
الدفاع عن السيادة الروسية على
اي طرف كان سواء من الناتو او من
تحركاتنا. ورغم هول المخاوف. هنا
قائد القوات الجوية الامريكية
الجنرال الكسوس يكشف عن مواجهة
محتملة مع روسيا بسوريا. مشيرا
على هذه المناطق يعتبر اعتداء
مباشرا على ارض روسية. واي دولة
منذ الحرب العالمية الثانية.
هجوم صاروخي عنيف تزامن مع اعلان
الروسية ضد اوكرانيا ونشر المزيد
من القوات بالجهة الشرقية. كما
اي دولة اوروبية. هنا روسيا تلعب
بالبيضة والحجر. كييف اعلنتها
على اراضي اوكرانيا لكننا نريد
مساعدات تتوافق مع وتيرة
الملتهبة. ليضيف ان خسائر الجيش
الاوكراني بلغت واحدا وستين الفا
وثلاثون قتيلا دون الكشف عن عدد
الجرحى وذلك حسب تصريحه. لكل فعل
في اوكرانيا. مشيرا الى ان هذا
لا يمثل سوى جزء ضئيل عدد
واوضح ان روسيا ستستدعي ثلاثمائة
الف جندي احتياط لتعزيز قواتها
ستدعم او ستشارك في الحرب بهذه
المناطق سترد روسيا من باب
وشيكة. السلطات الموالية لموسكو
في خرسون وزبروتشا والدونسكو
تعلن عن اجراء استفتاء شامل بشأن
ضم الاراضي الخاصة بهم الى
بدراسة اسلحة الناتو التي
استحوذت عليها القوات الروسية في
الجوازات الحمراء الداكنة تظهر
للعلن لتحمل مؤشرات حرب باتت
الوسائل المتاحة لنا لحماية
روسيا وشعبها هذه ليست مزحة. لم
اسلحة الدمار الشامل وهي اكثر من
تلك التي تمتلكها دول حلف
يكتفي بوتين بذلك وحسب اذ طالب
قطاع التصنيع الحربي الروسي
بوتين لا يمزح. بعد ان قال بوتين
كلمته الاخيرة واعلن التعبئة
الاراضي الروسية. مهلا مهلا.
اتعلمون ماذا يعني استفتاء? بكل
بالماكرة. واردوغان يصل لحل
نهائي لانهاء الحرب وقائد القوات
عنوانا لحرب عالمية قادمة.
بلادنا لديها مجموعة متنوعة من
الجزئية للجيش الروسي. ها هو
يبتسم ابتسامة خفيفة لتكون
روسي كارثي. فما هذا القرار وحلف
الناتو يقول كلمته الاخيرة ويعلن
واسطول الصين البحري يطلق تحذيره
الاخير قبل ان يطلق رصاصته
الجوية الامريكية يعلن حربا
وشيكة مع روسيا في هذه الدولة.
القسام الجناح العسكري لحركة
المقاومة الاسلامية حماس
الصفوف الخلفية بقداس جنازة
الملكة اليزابيث الثانية. ترامب
حدث لامريكا خلال عامين فقط من
حكمه. تصفه اسرائيل بالمطارد
العائلة الابراهيمية في ابو ظبي.
انسيتم يا ابناء زايد ماذا كان
السفيرة الامريكية في اوكرانيا
التعبئة الروسية مؤشر ضعف
حماية السيادة الوطنية. عزيزتي
الصين لقد اوشك رصيد سيادتك على
التركي دعا طرفي الحرب في
اوكرانيا للوصول الى مخرج مشرف
بوتين بينما سلطة كييف تعلن عن
طلب مساعدات عسكرية عاجلة ذات
حربية اخترقت هذا الخط الذي
يتوسط مضيق تايوان. ليأتي الرد
التأهب العسكري خلال الساعات
الماضية. وزارة الدفاع
داعيا بكين الى التعلم من درس
الغزو الروسي الفاشل لاوكرانيا
التايوانية قالت انها رصدت اربعا
وعشرين طائرة عسكرية صينية سفن
بالنسبة لهم بمثابة مزاح صبياني.
يا لا ثقلي مزاحك يا قديروف اذا
وواشنطن لن تعترف بمطالبات روسيا
بهذه الاراضي الاوكرانية. رئيس
ومائتين وسبعة قتلى وتسعة
واربعين الفا وثلاثمائة وثمانية
صافرات الانذار تدوي في كامل
اوكرانيا بعد اعلان بوتين الاخطر
الارقام الفلكية. ليكشف ان لدى
روسيا الكثير من الموارد البشرية
اوكرانيا وزير الدفاع الروسي
سيرجي شويجو لا يتحدث الا بلغة
الاشخاص الذين يمكن استدعاؤهم في
البلاد والبالغ عددهم نحو خمسة
خيار السلام هو الاساس. وان
تهديدات بوتين باللجوء لاسلحة
والمطارد والمطلوب لقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لتعتبرها
لتبادل مائتي اسير واصفا هذه
الخطوة بالايجابية. الرئيس
اوكرانيا ليصل صدى انفاس تهديدات
فوتن الى حلف الناتو. الامين
بكل ثقة. سنقاتل على كل سنتيمتر
زيلنسكي لن يكون للروس موطئ قدم
الى ان الوجود الروسي في سوريا
صار اكثر عدوانية منذ غزو
اختصار اذا نجح ستكون هذه
المناطق ارضا روسية. واي اعتداء
الناتو. اذا كانت وحدة اراضينا
مهددة فاننا وبلا شك سنستخدم كل
الاولى. بينما بوتين يتغزل بام
الدنيا مصر فماذا يريد منها؟
حالة الطوارئ القصوى. بينما كييف
تطلب المساعدة بشكل عاجل. فهل
واشنطن النداء وحليف بوتين
المقرب يعلن عن خطة عسكرية وصفت
فبعد اعلان التعبئة العامة
العالم يصحو على هول فاجعة قرار
هذا امر عسكري ويجب ان ينفذ. علم
وينفذ. صافرات الانذار لا تتوقف.
فماذا برأيكم في الايام القادمة.